do you want me to get into my homeowner
please do when I wrote this book people
thought he was going to be a little
lavender sort of scented memoir and I
said well action Fred's not going to be
and then everybody said oh I ain't gonna
buy it for my mother and I said well I'm
not sure I do have your mother's
broad-minded I've sent it to my colony I
had the most fantastic wedding at her
highs treated as a son there were three
tents three I had three wedding cakes
and Tony Snowden took my wedding
photographs and I follow rather rudely
called him turn his snapshot anyway
there I was having had this amazing
wedding wonderful wedding dress and we
were going to Paris for my honeymoon and
we arrived very late at night at the
Lahti hotel and went up to the maginot
some bright old sweet
well he laid on I went to see was my
honeymoon I mean that was rowing for a
night of passion and then the next day
we spent looking that we went to the
Louvre or something
before brothers and then it said well
I've got a great treat for you
and so obviously it's Phil I thought
dinner at the Ritz you know I put on my
best dress all right something we got
into the car and I did rather see I saw
the Ritz miles away but all three went
to the Ida Scott and we stopped at this
really seedy hotel my heart sank
we went to this room and there were two
seats they were they were wing back
velvet seats as I said and on the bed
were two really disgusting people making
love about back in my chair close my
eyes and I ripped it simply didn't want
to look at Collier know what he was
doing
saying would you like to join it kind of
I just said Akane I can't think call him
why you took me only so I thought it
might you know I was a virgin you see I
really never made love to her she used
to go off to a it was a brothel
you're tellin are you so I think it was
safe to say Colin Colin was a colorful
character
[Music]
you